los peruanos viven en el tercer día de
un paro de transportistas quienes
mantienen más de cinco vías bloqueadas
que interconectan salidas e ingresos de
las principales ciudades del país esta
medida de fuerza es acatada en sólo ocho
regiones del perú pero la decenas de
conductores que apagaron sus vehículos
de carga afecta el normal flujo de
transporte los manifestantes exigen al
gobierno del presidente de pedro casilla
que ponga control al alza de combustible
y que cumpla con las promesas que
acordaron en las reuniones con
funcionarios del estado las protestas se
trasladarán a lima en los próximos días
diversas federaciones agrarias anuncian
que se movilizarán a la capital del perú
para realizar el paro agrario los días
27 y 28 de julio exigirán al presidente
de pedro casi hoy al congreso la
denominada segunda reforma agraria y
mayor respaldo técnico y económico para
las mujeres siempre es el campo
precisamente al 28 de julio el
presidente pedro casi cumple un año en
el poder en medio de escándalos
políticos y diversas protestas según la
defensoría del pueblo en perú se lleva a
más de 200 conflictos sociales y en la
mayoría de ellos el gobierno de casio no
ha podido solucionar a pesar de que se
han instalado mesas de diálogo